para que tal recordemos que la oposición
incluso antes de comenzar este proceso
electoral que aseguraba que no había
plenas garantías en venezuela para unas
elecciones libres y justas aún así
decidió participar precisamente para
recuperar espacios y comenzar a reanudar
recuperar la confianza en el voto por
parte de sus seguidores con múltiples
irregularidades antes y durante el
proceso electoral desde el centro de
votación que todavía a mediodía no
estaban funcionando en su totalidad el
llamado después de las seis de la tarde
cuando debía cerrarnos en una votación
del propio nicolás maduro y los
dirigentes del chavismo a la denominada
'operación remate para que continuaran
en seguidores del oficialismo votando lo
que hace que no sea un proceso
totalmente transparente sin embargo la
derrota de la oposición sólo puede
adjudicarse a la propia oposición que no
fue unida a estos comicios si separan
los resultados de las distintas grupos
de oposición que participó quizás
hubiese podido obtener otras cuatro o
cinco naciones en el mapa de venezuela
no fuera prácticamente totalmente rojo
podría haber ganado unas tres o cuatro
gobernaciones imagen las alcaldías se
puede ver que el partido socialista
unido de venezuela se alzó con 205
alcaldías sin embargo en la última
elección tenían trescientas es decir
perdió cerca de 100 alcaldías la mesa de
unidad democrática tuvo 59 y la alianza
democrática un poco de 37 alcaldías esto
también tiene una importante revés para
la administración de nicolás maduro pues
sí obtuvo en la mayoría de las
gobernaciones pero con menos votos en
esta oportunidad falta todavía conocer
el informe que dará este martes la
misión de observación de la unión
europea que anunció que a horas de
mediodía daría una rueda de prensa
precisamente para dar con los sensores
de entonces